hey very good right thanks again
move to full screen okay
[Music]
yeah so there was a very good question
for the break so
we we use this reflection coupling and
then if we look at the distance process
it sometimes increases the distance
and it sometimes decreases the distance
and on average you don't gain
so then uh how how can this be
or maybe i should wait for a few seconds
okay so on average you don't gain and
and so how how can you gain from
something like that
and
so there are somehow two answers to that
uh
so
one one thing you can see that you gain
is
uh if you look at the distance between x
t and y t this is really some one
dimensional process
and the fluctuations the noise is done
in such a way that adjusts this
one-dimensional process gets
fluctuations
so so somehow if you look at the
difference of the two it will of the two
brownian motions it will also give you
only something one-dimensional because
you do this
reflection
and so so you have a one-dimensional
process which now randomly oscillates
and then you know if you have something
like this then after some time it will
hit zero
so it will make the distance process hit
zero in a finite time
and and once you hit zero you're at the
same position and if you're at the same
position then you move on with
synchronous coupling and then you stay
at the same position
so that's somehow the original argument
of linville and rogers so they showed
that it meets in a finite time and then
from this you get total variation bounds
now i'd like to give a different
argument
which is saying that you can get a
contraction in such a wasserstein
distance but only if you choose such a
concave function
and so why is that well if you have your
distance process it sometimes goes up
sometimes goes down in average you don't
gain
but now you apply a concave function to
the distance process
so then when you go up
because the function is concave you lose
less
and if you go down by the concavity you
gain more
so now if you apply this concave
function then on average you gain
and in that way you can really get an
average gain
not in the usual l one wasserstein
distance but in this concave distance
and uh so this you can use and so you
can get the following
so so our condition is now the following
for example so we still assume strong
convexity but only outside a given ball
there are also other results which avoid
this but in the simplest result we
assume strong convexity but outside a
given ball
with fixed radius r
and then
globally we just assume an upper lip
shifts bound with constant l so just in
one just one-sided lipschitz bond
yeah so that means we only assume the
convexity at large distances
but
inside we only assume
this bound here
and we assume that this constants l k
and r are given
now if this is the case then you can
design
such a concave function f
which looks like this
and such that
with respect to this concave function f
the wf distance will be contracted
so you can show you can design a concave
function f such that
the average of f of the distance process
is exponentially decaying with a rate c
that you can explicitly compute
yeah so the trick is somehow that if you
look at this distance at this difference
here then this
you you have something like martingale
plus something or even a sub martingale
but then if you apply this concave
function it turns it into a super
martingale so into something that is
really contracting
okay so the statement is you can find
the concave function f which looks the
following way it has jump at zero
okay i come to the question in a second
it has a jump at zero
so this is
because we want to be able to bound the
total variation distance we don't have
to include the jump but we can
then it starts with slope one then the
slope goes down until a certain
radius r1 and then afterwards the slope
stays constant so then it's again linear
so you can find such a function which is
explicitly given
and
explicit constants c a m r1 so a is this
constant here m is the slope
c is this decay rate and r1 is this
constant
and they only depend on these parameters
lk and r
such that you get this contractivity
now and this you can prove by ito's
formula
and then as a consequence you get the
contractivity in this wf distance
okay so now there was a question
uh yeah this is andre here um so is the
dependence uh on r typically exponential
in in the little c
uh the dependence on r well this depends
[Music]
so
yeah if if you have i mean if you have a
potential like a double well
then what will enter is uh yeah so so
then you will have something exponential
actually worse than exponential because
uh somehow
uh the the
non-convexity can cause you to have such
such a mountain pass here
yeah something like this that you have
to cross
and this will slow down
uh your convergence exponentially in the
height of the mount
in the height of this mountain pass and
that will be reflected here
on the other hand if
if you're in a situation where you do
not have strong convexity but maybe
still convexity
so maybe some flat piece
then it will not be exponential
thanks
okay
so that's what you can get and
so all the con so so all the constants
that occur here
and this function f they can be
explicitly written down
and they only depend on these parameters
lk and r
and so this tells you if your lk and r
if you can choose them in a fixed way
then you get dimension free bounds
of course that's a big if
you assume that outside a ball of fixed
radius you have strong convexity of
course in many situations the ball will
depend on the radius will depend on the
dimension and then you do not get
dimension free results
okay but if you have that you get
dimension free results there are also
some variants of this approach which
give dimension free results in other
contexts
okay so then the bound this this bound
also gives you total variation bounds
that was another shortcoming of the
synchronous coupling
because you have this jump in the
distance function and because of this
you can just upper bound the total
variation distance by this wf distance
and so if you have this wf decay then
you get also bounds for the total
variation distance yeah just
just use
uh this inequality here
okay and it also allows arbitrary
initial laws so you don't need any warm
start you can just start at a direct
mass you can just start at a single
point
answer question
yes
uh
can you hear me well
uh yes i'm home yeah
yeah so uh the question is about so here
you introduce this f
uh could we prove directly what you're
proving without the f but directly with
the indicator of of uh the positive real
line so that's the first question and
the second oh no okay so it's really
just a device to get to tv i was
wondering if this wf
gave us a bigger class of test functions
in the in the dual expression than you
would get if you were to use directly
the the tv dual formulation
so the point about the wf is you can get
bounce in all types of norms
but
if you want to get contraction then you
have to choose the right norm and this
wf is what gives you contraction
for example if you choose total
variation distance then first for a long
time your distance will maybe be equal
to one
or
close to one and then only after a long
time you will get a strong decay of the
total variation distance so you will not
have some uniform contraction in time
now this wf gives you really some way to
uniformly distribute the contractivity
over time
okay so yeah you so you use it as a as a
a yeah function i guess but so so yeah
and does f in itself like this wf in
itself does it give you
like so it's bigger than the tv so does
it give you
a
like are there any instances where you
can find functions that you know
guarantee that uh
uh
mu t and mu are against a bigger class
of test functions than the
continuous imbalance you would get for
tv
yes you can also bound
it you can also bound the elven
wasserstein distance by wf for example
okay thank you so that w one bonds
thank you
yeah and you could also do modifications
that such that you can control higher
whatever such time
distances but it would require some
modification of this basic approach
okay
so that's the coupling approach uh so
here are some more references this is
the original paper by lindvale and
rogers and
the way i looked at it was introduced in
in this paper well it it actually goes
back to results of chen and one
from about 2000 and then
in the way i put it here it was
introduced in this paper pdif
[Music]
okay so that was one approach it was the
coupling approach now i said there's the
second approach which is more analytic
and at this we look now
so we look at relaxation times and
both in l2 and for entropy
okay so i've so instead of russerstein
distances we are now considering
divergences which are some kind of
non-symmetric distances well not really
distances
so
the chi-square divergence of a
probability measure mu to mu
that's just the integral of
the relative density minus 1 squared
with respect to mu
if there is a relative density and
otherwise it's defined to be plus
infinity
similarly you can define the coolback
lipo divergence or the relative entropy
so this is just the integral of rho log
rhodium u if you have a density
and otherwise it's defined to be plus
infinity
so you see that these distances are
sometimes infinite
okay so now a nice thing about about
these divergences
which are just two special cases of
general divergences
is that if you take an invariant
probability measure and you have a
markov process with that invariant
measure
then
the chi-square divergence of your lower
time t
with respect to the invariant measure
is non-increasing in t and the same for
the relative entropy
so this is something you do not have for
wasserstein distances but you have for
these divergences
so therefore these are
very natural objects to look at
and now you can define relaxation times
for these quantities
and so the l2 relaxation time is just
defined as the first time
where
the chi-square divergence of your law at
time t with respect to mu
has decreased by a factor of one over e
with respect to the initial chi-square
divergence for any initial or new
of course this might be infinite but
then this inequality is trivially
satisfied
okay so the same you can define for
relative entropy so the entropy
relaxation time is just the first time
where the relative entropy has decayed
by a factor one over e for any initial
law
again note that
this can be infinite so for example if
mu is a dirac measure it will typically
be infinite
okay so now you want to control mixing
times by these
but
this is
not possible without further restriction
because uh
of these infinities here
so if you have the wrong initial law
your right hand side will just be
infinite and and so
the statement on these relaxation times
will mean will mean nothing for this
initial law
yeah so therefore we have to restrict
ourselves to nice initial laws and
that's what is called a warm start
so we have to restrict ourselves to an m
warm start so an m warm start means uh
the
the initial law has a density with
respect to the invariant measure which
is bounded
by a constant m
and then we can look at the mixing time
which only con takes into account
initial laws that are already m1
of course this is somehow restrictive
because usually if you can sample from
something and warm
then you have already done half of the
thing usually the problem is that you
cannot even create something in warm
okay but anyway
that this is what we can control in that
way
and so then you would define mixing time
as before so the first time where the
total variation distance is smaller than
epsilon
but for any initial law
which is n wall
question
yes
so can you show that after the mixing
time you still stay warm so this can be
iterated to obtain a rate of convergence
uh say again what can we expect so if
you start warm is it easy to show that
after that at the mixing time the
distribution is still going to stay warm
so they basically this condition on the
relative density is that preserved by
the evolution
um
okay so that would mean okay so that
would mean some l infinity contractivity
so this
it's just a bomb it doesn't have to be
contracted
okay okay
i'm not sure
maybe
i'm not too much an expert on m1 things
maybe there are people in the audience
who know better than me
thanks we can think about it answers yes
okay
should i continue
okay
okay so what you can do now is bound
this mixing time from an m warm start
uh by this relaxation times
and actually what you can see is
this is also not so difficult to show i
wrote exercise
uh
you can show that you can bound the
mixing time by the l2 relaxation time
but then you get a factor log m in front
and
you get something better for the entropy
relaxation time you can bound it by this
one but here you only get effect to a
loglog m in front
and that's important because often the m
will be exponentially large like if we
are in a product space
then then your uniform upper bound will
typically be exponentially large in the
dimension
and then if you take only the log
that might still not be good enough but
if you take log log it's usually quite
good
yeah so that means
in particular from these
entropy relaxation bonds you can
also get quite good bounds on mixing
times although restricted to an m1 start
okay so then the question is how can you
control these relaxation times
and here the nice thing is that there's
a nice analytics theory
which gives
analytic condition for exponential decay
of the chi-square divergence and the
relative entropy
in terms of functional inequalities
and
so these are the following so we
introduce the dirichlet form which is
associated to our generator so that's
just the quadratic form
only a two-space with respect to the
measure mu
which corresponds to the generator
and by integration by parts you see that
in our case this quadratic form is just
the integral of gradient f gradient gdp
so that's our dirichlet form
and and now you assume reversibility
yeah so you assume that v is
minus gradient of u
part of the results are also true if you
do not have reversibility but in that
case they are usually not so sharp
okay so we assume reversibility then you
have the following equivalence
you have exponential decay of the
chi-square divergence
with a pre-factor e to the minus t over
c
if and only if you have a primary
inequality that means if and only if you
can bound the variance of the function f
so this quantity here
by the constant c
times the dirichlet form
for any smooth test function
yeah so
exponential decay of chi-square
divergence is equivalent to a
procurement inequality and similarly you
can show
that exponential decay of the relative
entropy
with this rate
is equivalent to a logarithmic sovereign
inequality and logarithmic solar
inequality is a bit stronger than
concavity inequality it says that you
can bound the integral of f squared
times the logarithm of f squared and
then you have here some normalization
by
the dirichlet form
yeah so that turns out to be exactly
equivalent in the reversible case to the
exponential decay of the relative
entropy
okay let me give an informal proof of
the second statement this is very
informal uh the
rigorous proof would be much longer but
you see in principle how it works
so it's just an informal
computation with density so let's assume
the law at time t is absolutely
continuous with respect to our invariant
measure and it has a smooth density rho
t
and this density is bounded from below
by a strictly positive constant
i mean the rigorous part is then how to
get rid of these constraints but this i
skip here so let's assume this
now then you can compute the time
derivative of the relative entropy
so that's just the time derivative of
the integral of rho t log rho t d u
and now you can just formally
differentiate under the integral
and then you can use the kolmogorov
forward equation telling you that the
time derivative of rho t is equal to l
star rho t
actually here in the reversible case l
star is equal to l but it i write it in
that way because that's the equation in
the general case
yeah so you use this
and then you use the chain rule here
then you get this expression here
okay and now you put the l star to the
other side so put an l here
and then you see you have here
minus the dirichlet form evaluated at
rho t and log rho t
so the one disappears because if you
apply apply l to one you get zero
okay so that means you get this one here
minus integral nabla rho t naught log
rho t d mu
and now you can just apply the chain
rule and see that this is the same as
this expression here which is minus 4
the dirichlet form of the square root of
rho t
okay and now you insert your log sub
olef inequality your log sobolev
inequality tells you that you can
control the relative entropy by this
dirichlet form
and
so if you insert that then then you get
this bound here and then you have shown
that the time derivative of the relative
entropy is bounded from above by minus 2
over c times the relative entropy which
gives you the exponential decay
now so that's
very instructive to do this formal com
computation and
you you can make it rigorous but the
rigorous proof is much longer
okay so now you know that if you have
ponkari or obsolete inequality then you
can bound
uh your
relaxation time
or
your entropy relaxation time so you can
bound to relaxation the l2 relaxation
time by one half the primary constant in
the way i have defined it
i mean this one half depends on how you
define these constants
and you can define the entropy
relaxation time by one half the logs of
constant
and actually it turns out you have
equalities here in the reversible case
okay so that means your l2 relaxation
time is really
the pronghorny constant basically which
is the inverse of the spectral gap of
the generator and your entropy
relaxation time is really the looks of
the lift constant basically in the
reversible case
okay so then you're left with the
question how can you bound these
constants
uh
and well for poincare constants for
spectral gaps there are a lot of
techniques for bounding these
for logs overlap constants it's a bit
more difficult but meanwhile there are
also a lot of techniques
and i just give you the most widely used
result
which is a combination of the buckley
emery criterion and the holy sprut
perturbation lemma
and this says the following so suppose
your your potential you
can be decomposed in a strongly convex
part v
so for v the hessian is bounded from
below by a positive constant k
and a bounded perturbation w so
for w the oscillation that means the
supremum minus the infimum is bounded by
a constant by a finite constant m
now so for example if you have such a
double well potential
then you can do that
so so you can find
a strongly convex uh potential for
example which looks on the outside like
this one
looks on the outside like this one and
then on the inside stays strongly convex
something like that
and then you see your potential is a
bounded perturbation of this strongly
convex thing so you can apply this
criterion here
so if you have that then you get a log
sobolev inequality
and the constant is given by k
multiplied by e to the m
where m is the size of this perturbation
okay you have also other things like you
have factorization lemmas to get locks
of olive in higher dimensions and so on
uh very nice reference if if you want to
know more about these analytic
approaches
the standard reference is the book by
bakri gentile leduc
on analysis and geometry of markov
diffusion
operators yeah and the second reference
i gave here is some shorter introduction
to logs of will of inequalities
so if you somehow want the mainstream
one some of the main statements in a
more brief form that might be another
possibility
okay
any questions up to here
okay so then
we are through
with the continuous time markov
processes but now of course we want an
algorithm
so we have to discretize time
yeah and if we do that we end up with
what is usually called launch the
algorithms
but really it refers to the over-damped
launcher and dynamics
so
we again look at
the overdent launcher dynamics as we
introduced it before and now to get an
algorithm we discretize this
and well the easiest way to do is just
to do an euler discretization of course
you can also use more advanced
discretization schemes
but
also euler discretization here works
quite well in that case
okay so that if you do that if you look
at the euler discretization and the
transition step is given by so if you're
at position x
then you move to x minus h times nabla u
of x
plus square root 2h times set where that
is standard normally distributed
now so you have
an iteration with this transition step
and that defines a markov process in
discrete time so a markov chain
of course you have to fix the step size
h here
okay so that gives a markov chain and
the transition kernel has a density
which i have written down explicitly
here
[Music]
okay so you have this markov chain so
the first possibility is you now say
this markov chain is an approximation of
my diffusion so i just use this markov
chain for approximate sampling yeah so i
don't change anything i just use this
euler discretization
and if you do that then it's called the
unadjusted launch algorithm and also the
an unadjusted launch valve algorithm is
just simulating the euler discretization
of the overdent launcher and diffusion
okay so now
let's let's see what
which problems could occur with this
algorithm
so let's again look at our simplest
example where our target distribution is
the standard normal distribution
so that means gradient of u of x is just
x
now in that case if you look at that
process here so from x you move to x
minus h times x plus square root 2 h z
this is just an auto regressive process
so this is just a very simple gaussian
process in discrete time
and you you can compute everything
explicitly for this process
in particular you can easily find the
invariant measure
and it's this one
so it's a normal distribution with mean
zero
and the covariance matrix is the
identity but multiplied by a prefactor
so that means it's not the same as our
target distribution mu
so our discretization has a different
invariant measure
than the diffusion process of course
that's not not a surprise if you
discretize why should you preserve the
invariant measure if you just discretize
in some way
okay so we have a different invariant
measure
and that's of course a disadvantage that
means you have a bias but not just a
fixed time but even asymptotically a
bias that does not vanish in the limit
so if you fix your step size h
then you will just approximate the the
wrong invariant measure so you can run
as long as you want
you you will not get closer than
the arrow which is between these two
invariant measures so this you have to
take into account
on the other hand of course if h is
small then this asymptotic bias gets
small
and now let's say let's see how small it
is
so we look at the l to wasatch time
distance between u h and u we could also
look at some other distances but this is
the easiest one to compute
yeah so that was the minimal of the l2
norm over all couplings and here
turns out that in this case the
synchronous coupling is optimal because
these are both gaussian distributions
so
both centered gaussian distribution so
you find that the synchronous coupling
is optimal
and so therefore you can exactly write
this l2 wasserstein distance in this
form here
yeah so this is just a synchronous
coupling between that drawn from mu
and this is a
random variable drawn from mu h
that's the synchronous coupling of these
two
okay and now this you can compute of
course you get exactly this value here
which behaves like one quarter h d to
the one half
so that's the bias between these two
measures
and and now you want to make this
smaller than some given epsilon
and then you see in order to do that you
have to choose h of the order d to the
minus one half
times epsilon inverse at least
yeah so here you see a disadvantage
towards macropolis algorithms
so for metropolis algorithms if you have
exponential convergence to equilibrium
then this will only depend
logarithmically on epsilon inverse but
here it will really depend on epsilon
inverse because you have this asymptotic
bias
now on the other hand what you get here
is d to the minus one half so you have
to choose h of this order
least
yeah so then the question is is this
also enough
and
you can give a positive answer to that
in certain places
and i've just stated a simple result but
there are much better results available
so here i assume strong convexity just
for simplicity this is not necessary i
assume global lipschitz
and then the third thing i assume is
that you have
a
strong arrow bound on the euler
discretization
so you can bound the strong error of the
euler discretization so that means the
l2 norm of the difference between the
euler discretization and the diffusion
uniformly on a finite time interval say
zero one for the diffusion
by some constant m times h
okay and then
what you get is uh
that that you can bound
this distance between the two invariant
measures
by this constant here times nh
and as a consequence you get that you
can bound the distance of the euler
chain after n steps to equilibrium
in this way here
okay as i said uh this can be relaxed
substantially and actually uh the real
expert on this unadjusted launchville
algorithm is alan dermous who's also
participating in this program
and and you can find his papers with
eric moline
and with the water lee which give
much better results than this
but
the question that you have to answer now
is how does this m depend on the
dimension
and this is something we have looked at
in a recent work with allah
and it turns out that the m depends on
the dimension like d to the one half
for nice models
so that's the same as in the gaussian
case but for general models it might
have
a worse dimension dependence
now so that's something interesting for
for actually a quite broad class of nice
models you really get this deep with one
half dependence here
but uh there there are
i mean we do not have really an example
but
it seems quite clear that there are
models where you get this worse
dimension dependence
so when you talk about models you're
talking about you
yes i'm talking about you exactly and so
what kind of properties do you need for
you i mean is it like i mean
yeah basically it's yeah that there's
some bound on on
uh what is it uh
um
[Music]
so so on
you have to take the laplacian of the
gradient of u
and i i think you have to take this
squared euclidean norm and you have to
look at how that depends on the
dimension
and it turns out that for example for
product models or for models that have a
density with respect to a gaussian
or for
mean field models and things like that
this dimension depends is like this d to
the one half
but but
we believe it's not the case for general
models
uh was there another question
i know i just said thank you
okay
thanks
okay so that's the unadjusted launcher
and
[Music]
so alternatively of course
you you can now use
the euler step just as a proposal
for metropolis hastings
and if you do that
then you get the metropolis adjusted
longitude algorithm
and this now has the correct
invariant measure but it's
mathematically harder to analyze
now first you can get a negative result
again using conductance so you can show
that again if you have gaussian target
distribution
then you have a similar result as for
random work metropolis so the mixing
time if you start in the neighborhood of
zero is lower bounded
by e to the h squared d over four
so for random work metropolis you had
here h times d now you have h squared
times d so you have gained something
okay but it tells you that if you want
to start from a cold start if you for
example want to start at zero then you
have to choose h of order d to the minus
one half
yeah so you don't have a chance
otherwise uh
this is only for a cold start so for a
warm start it might actually improve
here
okay and then the question is can you
also have a converse result
and
there's a very nice paper i maybe would
be interested in to learn more because
there are some also here in the audience
i think
uh which which gives some converse
result and says
that that you can get mixing from a warm
start in order d to the one half log
these steps
and that was actually an open
problem because uh together with this
with these uh acceptance rejection steps
that you have
in mala
it's not so easy
to to identify the precise order of the
algorithm
okay
so then i come to the last part
so somehow all these algorithms
were quite traditional that we looked at
so far
and recently there's some interest in
looking at mcmc methods
where you use degenerate noise
and so what's the idea behind that
somehow vaguely the idea is if you have
too much randomness
then this could lead to slow mixing
because you have something to diffuse
like diffusive behavior which is slow
and
other things
so injecting too much randomness into
your system might not be so good
so somehow if you inject less randomness
it makes the mathematical analysis
harder but
it might be beneficial
okay and then
we come actually to a very parallel
thing like we saw in the optimization
so in the optimization
then uh
we were also looking at
at second-order methods after the first
order methods
and we have something similar now here
we also look at second order and the
first second order thing in continuous
times launchman dynamics
so in large vein dynamics if you look at
it as at an equate as an equation for x
it's now a second order ste
but we write it as a first order sde by
introducing the velocity that means the
derivative of the position
so we change the state space now to
having position and velocity so that
means the state space is now rd times rd
but the velocity is not is only
artificial
yeah so we are only using it
to
invent
new dynamics
from the point of view of something
from the physical point of view of
course it's a different story
okay so our sde is now derivative of
position is the velocity
and then the derivative of the velocity
is minus the gradient of u of x t and if
you do this on your on its own then this
is just hamiltonian dynamics
and hamiltonian dynamics turns out to
have the invariant measure that we will
be interested in but of course it's
usually not mixing because it preserves
the energy and and so it's not ergodic
so we have to add something to it to
make it ergodic and then there are two
possibilities
about the second possibility we will
hear
this afternoon in the talk by nishit
vistnoy which is hamiltonian monte carlo
and
so the first possibility is to to add
something like this
so so you add brownian motion times a
parameter square root 2 gamma which
corresponds to random collisions
and you add a damping term minus gamma
vt
yeah and this equation here is really a
somehow physical brownian motion so this
is really like particles in physics
are moving if they are driven by
brownian motion
okay so in physics the parameter you
introduce here is the friction gamma you
could also introduce a mass here and
this might actually be a matrix but i
dropped this here for simplicity
okay so let's launch one dynamics
it has a unique solution for given
initial law it's a markov process on r2d
and its invariant measure is actually
the boltzmann gibbs measure which is in
this case is just the product
of the measure mu we are interested in
and a standard normal distribution
so that means if we can sample from this
measure then we can also sample from mu
because mu is just the first marginal of
the measure
okay and the boltzmann gibbs
distribution this has a density again
with respect to the back measure and the
density is just e to the minus the
hamiltonian so e to the minus the total
energy
and total energy if the mass is equal to
one is just u of x the potential plus
one half v squared
okay so that's the dynamics that
preserves this measure
and
somehow since it's a second order
dynamics and since we only inject the
noise in in the second component we have
less randomness
now you can also say it's moving more
more smoothly brownian motion is
wiggling around all time
but here it's moving was
more smoothly because the brownian
motion is only in the velocity and if we
go to the position
then we are integrating once more
okay so we denote by pt the transition
function of this markov process
okay and then we might ask about the
mixing properties of this dynamics
and there we again look at our
running example so we look at a normal
distribution as a target
now i can take a normal distribution
with a general covariance matrix c so c
is a general symmetric positive definite
matrix that's our target distribution
and so that means our function u of x is
now this one
and then the sde can now be written in
this form so
the derivative of xv
differential of xv is just minus a
matrix a times xv dt plus noise
so that means that's linear sde
and the matrix a takes this form
okay so you see that the process xv is a
gaussian process because it's described
by a linear
by by a linear drift perturbed
additively by bromine motion
and so in that case
your solution to the sde is a gaussian
process
so that means all laws are gaussian and
can be computed explicitly
okay and that allows us again to study
this
exactly
so in particular we can look at the
wasserstein contraction coefficient and
it's easiest to do in l2
so that what what is that so we look at
the time t
and then we see how how much the
wasserstein distance
is has decreased up to time t so we look
at
the wasserstein distance between the
lower time t when starting at mu and the
lower time t when starting at nu divided
by the wasserstein distance of mu and mu
and we take the supremum over on u and u
okay so that's the wasserstein
contraction coefficient
and
you can show
that actually you can restrict yourself
here to direct measures so you can
replace mu and new by direct measures
and and you get the same supreme here
so this is the same as the supremum over
all x not equal to y and if you insert
here for mu and eu dirac measures then
you get here p
you get here pty
and here you get the wasserstein
distance of dirac measures delta x and
delta y and that's just the euclidean
distance of x and y
okay so you you can write your
wasserstein contraction coefficient in
this form
and now in this case ptx and pty are
both gaussian measures
with the same covariance
and so therefore you know that the
synchronous coupling is optimal
so therefore you can compute this w2
distance and if you do that you'll find
that it's exactly equal
to the operator norm of e to the minus
ta
where a is this matrix
okay and now you're in business because
you know how this operator norm behaves
it behaves asymptotically like e to the
minus t lambda where lambda is the
bottom of the spectrum of a so the
infimum of the real part of the spectrum
of a
ah and this you can compute explicitly
for this matrix because you can
diagonalize and so you just have to do
it for two times two matrix
and and then you find
that this decay rate lambda is given by
gamma over two
times one minus the square root of this
positive part here
where the sigma i squared
are the eigenvalues of the covariance
matrix
okay and what this means you see best in
a picture
if i not now draw lambda as a function
of gamma
then you see as long as gamma is small
then this number here will be larger
than one so this positive part will
vanish and you will just have gamma half
so as long as gamma is small
this will increase linearly in gamma
the lambda
and that's the underdamped region
now of course if gamma is zero if you
don't put noise you do not have mixing
it's not ergotic then if you put noise
if you put more noise it increases
linearly with the noise
but now it does not increase all the
time it stops increasing at a certain
point
and this is the point where in the
spectral decomposition for a
you you change between real and
non-real spectrum
so at this point it changes
and then it goes down again
yeah so you see
your decay rate depends on gamma but
it's not optimal to choose gamma as
large as possible so to inject as much
noise as possible
but there's a certain amount of noise
that gives you the fastest mixing
yeah and this is exactly given by gamma
equal to 2 over the maximum of the sigma
ice
and if you do that
then your lambda
is just one over the maximum of the
sigma ice now sigma i's are something
like standard deviations so that's
something like one over the size of the
system somehow
so this is kinetic behavior so your rate
behaves like one over the size of the
system
yeah so if you choose the second order
dynamics and
you you're in this region between under
then and over them then you get this
kinetic behavior which is faster than
diffusive behavior
and again there's a connection to
yesterday where we also saw
this uh
three
this factor three
uh which
was at
somehow a borderline between under them
and over them and and
what's the best you could do
question
can can you make the same analysis in
this gaussian case if you decouple the
gamma that you put in front as a
friction coefficient and the one that
you put as a noise term
so if you take two parameters for those
yes you can you can that's going to tell
you to take this the same value
you get you get a different invariant
measure if you don't take the same value
i mean taking the same value so if we
look at the sde here
we have to do it in this way if we want
to get the right invariant measure
yeah so you can put say some other
factor here in front
but this will change your invariant
measure then the invariant measure will
not be e to the minus u but for example
e to the minus beta u
okay
i have a question too
yes
um so in this discussion example the
uh the potential is is it like max uh
one over sigma i strongly conducts so is
the contraction rate exactly the same as
what we have for the uber
no it's better than for over than longer
so for overdenk launcher you would get
uh sigma i squared here
so for over the launch one this is
diffusive and so therefore you get
one over the system size squared
but here you get just one over the sigma
i
see so actually like the eigenvalues of
c are sigma i squared
yes the eigenvalues of c are the sigma i
squared
so sigma is are like standard deviations
okay good so this shows that you can
really gain by degenerate noise but that
you have to do it in the right way that
you really have to
to inject
the right amount of noise
and of course this is only in the
gaussian case and now you can ask can
you prove something like this more
generally
and
yeah there are indeed some results doing
that recently
so first in the strongly convex case you
can use synchronous coupling and that
has first been done in the paper by
chang at al
and then improved in in a paper by
dalali lyan and trio durong
now in the non-convex case you can again
use some reflection coupling but not the
one i introduced you actually have to
design some special reflection coupling
for this degenerate noise situation
which only couples to to a hyperplane
and but but then you can also get
results
in corresponding results in non-convex
cases
so these are the coupling approaches and
then recently there has been a very
interesting analytic approach by
xiao lu and wang
so they consider a fairly general case
assuming a warm start
and what they use is a functional
inequality but actually a new one a
space-time contrary inequality
and so this is a recent approach due to
armstrong mura
which allows you uh to deal with such
situations with degenerate noise
and uh this seems also to be quite
powerful and to to give quite
interesting and sharp results
so
seems certainly worse to look more
detailed also in this approach
okay so that that was uh laundry and
then we will hear in the afternoon about
hamiltonian monte carlo
and
the difference is
easily explained you again have the
hamiltonian dynamics
but instead of adding this part in the
diffusion you just run hamiltonian
dynamics for some time
and then you inject your noise by
choosing a new velocity either
completely newly choosing the velocity
or partially updating the velocity
so if you do that you get another
dynamics
which corresponds to something like a
boltzmann equation
and so then we can ask the same question
what what can we say about this dynamics
and and about this uh
we will hear uh in in the talk behind
this [ __ ]
this afternoon or for me this night
okay
that's all on my talk since i can't be
here i thought it might be nice if you
later you have questions that there's a
possibility to ask
so i will avail i will be available
tomorrow
on zoom
before the conference starts
on on this
zoom link
okay thank you very much and then
yeah other questions
questions
so you the longitudinal diffusion can be
seen as gradient designed with noise so
what if we try to do it with say newton
steps
like that is normalize the gradient with
the hessian at the point
um
yes
so okay so there's uh
there's also the riemannian manifold
hmc message
i'm
but but i haven't
[Music]
considered this but maybe this goes in
this direction um i don't know
i i think there's some like other i
think ozaki discretization or something
i guess there's some other version of
this that does do like a hashing type
like newton type of update but i'm not
quite sure like how much of analysis
there is
yeah so so definitely i'm not not aware
of
of results in this direction
uh
it it might be an interesting thing to
look at definitely
thank you
it looks like this sheet added a comment
there on the chat
all right any other questions
uh yeah so i was curious about this
result that um you mentioned about i
mean that you can pick somehow the f
um i think it was when you were
i mean this there was an f that would
define a metric and under this metric
you had this contraction
uh you know and it was kind of like one
specific one that would work
and yesterday we heard about kind of
jurassic convexity and there was one
similar um situation where you had a
function that
with the wrong metric you didn't have
any sort of complexity but if you choose
the metric appropriately then suddenly
you have
kind of genetic complexity so i was
wondering if there's somehow a
connection between these two situations
maybe
um if there is something like like like
that like that you're picking your
metric in such a way that your f somehow
is making something you that's it come
back in some sense i was wondering if
there's such a connection
yeah i'm sorry i did not yet attend the
talk
the the for me night talks yesterday
because that was around midnight
i'm still planning to
to listen to the video
so
yeah i i
yeah i i
i don't know i
all right is there
no other questions
please join me in thanking andreas again
[Applause]
oh